let's try seven-one-seven what about the
seven one seven area code caller from
seven one seven what's your name where
you calling from and what's on your mind
today oh wow I actually got on yes my
name is Logan
I am from anvil Pennsylvania alright
let's turn Logan up pat and oh I'm I'm
sorry can you hear me now we can yeah go
ahead
is this better I I was on speaker that's
better no speaker please to all callers
a disclaimer
go ahead oh sorry
um I was just wondering
the fundamental idea whether you think
he's a hypocrite or not on this of kind
of the isolationism idea that Donald
Trump has with trade maybe I might even
go a little further and say just so long
non-interventionism what are your
thoughts on that do you think it could
work like limiting trade limiting
outsourcing yeah so listen like here's
the thing Logan yeah I think I got it I
think I got the question the this idea
of total isolationism it's sometimes
appealing when it comes to a foreign
policy conflict or involvement in the
conflicts of others but what Trump
completely lacks an understanding of is
the way that we actually as an American
economy and the people of the United
States depend on many of these
relationships with other countries even
to just fund our day to day life so when
Trump talks tough with China Trump seems
to completely ignore that if we really a
Lee innate China as a trading partner a
ton of stuff is going to get way more
expensive for the American people
now if the products that people get that
are produced in China go way up in cost
yes there will be somewhat less
purchasing of those products but there
will be people who will continue
purchasing those products at a higher
cost
maybe they're American made or made
elsewhere and then they will have less
money to put into the businesses that
are right here in the United States or
they might start spending less on homes
or they might spend less on cars and it
will directly impact in a negative way
lots of other businesses that depend on
American spending so the idea of the
caricature of isolationism and and build
it here and buy it here and forget about
China and forget about all these other
countries that Trump has the guy doesn't
know anything right so to the extent
that we should take it seriously and I
don't know how seriously we should take
it there are it's sort of like
libertarianism taken to the extreme it's
just it's a joke the same type of
isolationism Trump is talking about
taken to its full conclusion is also
something that would be terrible for the
American economy period yeah and
actually one other question now what is
in the scenario now completely take
Trump out of the picture because he
would never do something like this but
what if we were to fraid what if on top
of raising the prices now we all have
like american-made products but what if
we were to increase the minimum wage
thus would increase like wages above
that so like if you raise the minimum
wage to say 20 dollars an hour yeah and
subsequently like uh subsequently like
the value of the American dollar the
value of the American dollar would
probably go down but people would be
able to purchase a more of the more
expensive american-made products god I
think in this sort of hyper fantasy
world that would Eric yeah I mean you'd
have to run the numbers on that I think
that it's not it's barely worth
discussing what was my chair almost
tipped over uh barely worth discussing
right now because it's not your question
so surprise me Logan that my chair
almost went completely off to the side
there that would have been an
interesting moment on the show it's just
I wouldn't even think about it in those
terms right now but as I mentioned by
the way the dollar has been falling
Trump talks only about the Dow Jones and
dust
average is way up of course only half of
Americans even have stocks or something
like that and but the dollars value
going down is something that directly
impacts way more American so very good
questions Logan we will continue
thinking about these issues as they are
very very important